boy no water mr. Jeremy Corbyn Thank You
mr. speaker the government has been
defeated again by an enormous majority
and they must now accept their deal
their proposal the one the Prime
Minister's put is clearly dead and does
not have the support of this house and
quite clearly
No Deal must be taken off the table
we've said that before and we'll say
that again but it does mean the house
has got to come together with a proposal
that could be negotiated the Labour
Party has put that proposal and we will
put we will put that proposal again
because the dangers the days of what the
Prime Minister proposing are basically
that we actually carries on threatening
us all with the danger of No Deal the
danger of that knowing full well the
damage that will do to the British
economy this party will put forward our
proposals again which are about a
negotiated customs union access the
market and protection of rights those
the ones will put forward we believe
there may well be there may well be a
majority for them but there will also be
the potential of negotiating them the
Prime Minister's run down the clock and
the clock has been run out on her maybe
it's time instead we are a general
election and the people
who their government should be
coin point of water
[Music]